cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump to this next
story this is big news ladies and
gentlemen Marine Corps leader orders
Safety Stand Down of all aircraft after
F-35 disappearance I want to give a
shout to that to the lectern guy because
he posted a meme of himself carrying the
missing F-35 out of the Capitol building
it was a funny day for people making fun
of this there was uh I have to find his
name but one of the congressmen posted
one of the milk cartons with the missing
so he's like if you find it call the dod
here's the story there was an F-35 uh
the pilot ejected it remained on
autopilot and no one knew where it went
and so everyone was very concerned that
it was flying around uh they found a
debris field I guess so it did crash
well but but now this is the crazy thing
that they say uh they're ordering the
Safety Stand Down apparently there have
been there have been a series of
failures there's been more than one they
say the Pentagon set in a statement that
the pause and operations would allow
units to discuss Aviation safety matters
and best practices during a Safety Stand
Down Aviation commanders will lead
discussions with their Marines folks and
fundamentals blah blah blah as he just
mentioned it was it was three different
incidents what was what was the time
periods like the past couple weeks yeah
I mean this is crazy man look at this
they said decision to stand down comes
into two deadly Marine Corps crashes
last month an F-18 pilot died during a
training flight near San Diego and three
marines died and more were wounded when
an osprey crashed off the coast of
Australia the Pentagon noted the two
previous accidents in its statement
Monday I'm sorry man I I mean no
disrespect I know you know these are men
and women in uniform they're losing
their lives in these instances but when
they lower the standards and they inject
the wokeness into our armed forces and
people of Merit don't want to be there
and people who probably shouldn't are
this is what you'll get and it's it's
not just in the in the military in the
Air Force or whatever in the Marines
it's going to be everywhere it's
possible that it is like what you're
saying is incompetence and that they
really have to shut down and make sure
these guys are trained or it could be
that our Machinery is getting hacked and
they are afraid that if they keep it up
and running that it's going to get
turned around on us
did you guys hear about the hacking that
just happened in Vegas like last week
let me tell you about the hacking in
Vegas it was everywhere it wasn't Vegas
it wasn't in Vegas this is crazy yeah
this like so first let me just slow down
say it because I'm gonna get excited on
this one Ian makes a really really good
point that we could be being attacked
and how do you check to know an osprey
Crush so it's easy for us to be like
yeah but it could be that the system had
had a worm implanted in the Opera in the
operating system the guidance system and
then it crashes and they're like it
looks like an accident now they order a
stand down I kind of feel like that's a
possibility but here's here's what's
crazy about Vegas
Caesar's entertainment got hacked they
paid the bill because they are morons I
think it was 40 million dollars
ransomware hit Caesar's Entertainment
Systems this is not just one Casino the
Caesar Caesar's entertainment is a is a
ton of different casinos like Arya MGM
got hit separate company and they said
we will not pay smart move however holy
crap in DC at the Nash at National
Harbor which is they clear National
Harbor is one of the highest grossing
casinos in the country my understanding
I could be wrong 600 million dollars
last year so what I'm told and if you
wanted to play there everything was Cash
like the olden days
it's I mean I kind of I I should have
gone and checked it out that because it
sounds crazy but what they were saying
what the guys were telling me is that
you'd go to a slot machine you could
only put cash in and when you print that
at a ticket they would come in hand pay
you because there was no machines to put
it anywhere that's what I'm talking
about there's no way in hell I'm gonna
settle for a USBC a central bank digital
currency are you crazy no one is going
to stand for that when the power goes
out can't do nothing the hell do you
expect let Society run oh dude worse
than that man so with with Caesars
paying the bill I mean it's remarkable
how stupid these people are but they're
probably thinking like look it's 40
million dollars we make billions every
year just pay it otherwise we could lose
you know insert amount of money yeah
what they don't get about this is that
the ransomware didn't go anywhere you
paid the bill your computer's turned
back on well you still gotta flash your
entire system you still got to rewind it
to get rid of that malware and you don't
know where it is they can do it again
they'll do it again and they will do it
again so MGM said we're not paying it
probably because they were like guys if
we pay this we lose the 40 million then
they could come right back a week later
and do it to us again what could also be
any one of us it could be all of our
bank accounts it just shows you that
they're getting in the money you know
they're getting the money off Caesars
they're they're they're fine this is an
attack like what you said and it was a
an attack that led to someone making
it's actually Joe Biden's ransomware so
he could help pay for the Ukrainian War
yeah man I'm surprised the F-35 didn't
end up in oh we found it was Urban
Ukraine yeah but some people thought
they turned to Cuba that just
autopiloted its way over to Cuba for the
Chinese to take over and study so this
is this is a crazy reality of where
we're at I think it makes it brings up a
really good point we should consider the
the military implications right I I
think it's fair to point out that the
lowering of Standards I think it's kind
of an Occam's razor but it's hard to
know for sure what what is the simpler
solution that our armed forces have been
in a state of decay with people retiring
resigning and not wanting to be involved
anymore because of the injection of
wokeness those are that's a true story
yeah or is it simpler to say we get
attacked they're ha cyber attacks are
legit and real and we are at war with
Russia whether anyone wants to admit it
or not yeah and people three three
crashes in a month could that be I I
feel like it sounds conspiratory I'll
say but we are in in war is it possible
that Russia is like let's start
attacking their infrastructure well and
Russia knows that we continuously miss
our our recruiting goals like it's not a
secret that we're not doing well in
terms of recruiting high quality
candidates we are open about the culture
that we are breeding the military I mean
videos of what was it one of the the
sailors like in uniform they spins and
he's in drag like these things go viral
all the time so I don't think it's a one
or the other I think it's a combination
of both people know that we are
vulnerable right now yeah look at these
wars sorry Trevor have you seen what
China's doing with their military
recruitment they're starting to train
little kids oh how old they have like
like straw figures with Japanese
Uniforms on them and these little kids
are stabbing them with like that makes
me think they're preparing for war in
the next 10 years A lot of people are
saying that a speculation just to get
like National uh to get these kids like
kind of brainwashed in the beginning
like they're not actually training them
but they want them to fight in 10 years
well they're preparing for it whether or
not they want it I don't know I don't
want it either I mean China does this
with everything right they're famous for
their gymnasts who get separated from
their their families at Young ages just
to train all the time to become the best
I mean it is about keeping up the
National Standard there they're having a
really big uh famine Lookout right now
because uh what's it the legion ping or
whatever he's he's like starting to talk
about world hunger is all of our or
world food production is all of our you
know responsibility and they're they're
saying that because of the droughts and
the uh the floods that their production
of food production is like really really
bad right now and then you got to
consider
what does a country do and they don't
have food for their people do they just
say yes we die or do they take food from
someone else oh yeah but they have a
pattern of letting you know China has
let 90 million people starve and die
before and have been family history with
them yeah it's in their history they're
not gonna admit it right like let's see
yeah it's not like they're gonna be like
oh please you end give us some extra
food they're just going to sacrifice
their people for it right think about
the military too you're you're a strong
soldier in the military you see what's
going on does this this does everything
that's happened in Ukraine if you were
to study everything that happened in
Ukraine and they were like you're
getting ready to okay now we got to send
American troops wherever you're going to
Ukraine what would you say you'd be like
pass right pass who would it get to it
would be down to people who probably
don't even know how to pull a gun out of
and we were already coming out of that
with Afghanistan right I mean we were in
the all of the conflict in the Middle
East for so long there were tons of
people who grew up feeling disintered
disenfranchised like right and then on
top of that there's a complete culture
of I I don't want to do this there's not
a culture of patriotism it's a good
thing you see it in some pockets of
society but overall we don't really have
any incentive to be in the military
other than the financial benefits which
for a lot of people it makes a huge
difference right being able to get on GI
Bill and have housing and stuff like
that but uh I think we are severely
disadvantaged so today I was about two
in the afternoon after I was reading
about this F-35 I was like I want to
join the military for the first time my
life and it wasn't to fight it was so
that we don't have to fight and it was
to protect and to serve as some sort of
intelligence aspect like I've been
thinking about drones getting hacked and
turned around on us for like seven years
is military not aware of that are they
not focused on that there's two there's
two trains of thought the first is that
the system is decaying and corrupt led
by morons and so good luck it's a
bureaucratic Nightmare and people don't
feel fulfilled because it's hard to move
around and do things properly without
playing some weird game the other
thought is
the actual US military is a well-oiled
machine run in secret through Black
Operations you'll never know yeah
pick one maybe it's both a little bit of
both huh I meet some I made some strong
military guys but they all seem not
pumped about the direction of like we're
talking about the direction of the
military the the the the guys that I
meet are that are like that are like
ready to to go
I believe are now rocking with civilians
like they're they're more aware of with
us and our communities and uh and and
staying visual on that side you know one
of those those are the type of guys that
just get accusations thrown against them
so they don't have to be dealt with one
day like oh this guy looks like he's
gonna start a revolution of some sorts
or they don't take the vaccine they get
kicked out yeah you're out of here yeah
that that was crazy which direction
generations of of military leadership
right there's still one to inherit these
positions we've got a strong leadership
I've met I've met a couple guys and I'm
sure to people listening and you guys
probably know some too that I met one
guy who was he was a captain and he was
just like I resigned he's like I'm out
and he said his intention was to run to
was to retire just go be in for his
whole career and then when they started
introducing critical race Theory stuff
he was like nope I'm out it's all you
that's what that was crossed my mind I
was like well if I joined the military
I'd get stuck in some bureaucracy and
have to follow orders that I don't agree
with and I don't know other than being
the president and trying to guide him
from the top I don't know how to help
and you're not going to have access us
to those people the dude who's going to
be above you could be woke for all you
know and he's gonna be like oh this
guy's a troublemaker go put him in a box
and also our country's becoming I love
our country by the way I don't want to
insult in any way but our country is
becoming something less desired to fight
and risk your life for with the way it's
the direction is trending it's like
there was a time where where people
would would die for their country
certainly and people would go to war and
go to battle and people do anything for
their country but when you look at what
we're dealing with today in today's
climate with with just the state of the
country it doesn't look like something
that everyone's just jumping forward to
to put everything on the line for I'm
more focused I feel that way about my
community and my family and my friends
I'm I'm like gung-ho about protecting
that infrastructure of community and and
in churches and and people that are that
are in my everyday life you know I just
I think it would be hard to get
people to to risk their lives for this
state of this country homelessness
everything that's going on it's a shame
and what you're doing serves the
military because it protects and
stabilizes the local communities so that
they don't have to worry about coming in
to defend it you're there you're going
to protect it right but we we gotta
start thinking about protecting the
local communities I think I'm doing
everything local I'm getting out of this
I'm trying to get out of it you already
do it I'm trying to get out of the
Matrix as much as possible I'm trying to
not support any corporations I'm trying
to get everything in my life local I'm
trying to be more involved in my
community I'm trying to be more of a you
know I'd like to be more of a leader in
my community because in case something
happens you know we're going to need
each other this is a scary thing
people don't know their neighbors and so
what happens when a crisis happens what
happens when the roads get shut down and
I'm not let's let's not even talk about
the apocalypse let's say like sometimes
it rains let's say you you live in your
neighborhood those of you that are
listening how many of you know your
neighbors I'm sure a lot of you do
because this the people who listen to
this show are on the higher end of the
uh of like awareness Spectra bell curve
or whatever to call it but let's say you
live in a neighborhood when I lived in
uh you know when I lived in Chicago for
instance when I was a teenager when I
was into my early 20s and rented an
apartment with my my friends like you're
on the second floor of a house I didn't
know anybody who lived anywhere near me
what happens if the road gets gets shut
down is a major accident storm hits
massive blizzard nobody can drive
there's no in and out there's no grocery
store they can't get supplies to the
store Who you gonna ask for help you
even know your neighbors you need people
need to talk like talk to their
neighbors build community so that in the
event of a flood a fire hurricane you
name it you have a plan for what you do
in the event and United what happens
look I keep hearing and that this is
going to sound like a crazy conspiracy
theory but what's the only word you've
heard in the last six months two years
the word AI right AI I was gonna do
everything I know bands that are like
hey I wrote the song for me no I I know
everybody saw my AI what are you gonna
do the data AI shows up but you're
you're gay to your community and and
it's just got to make its rounds to to
collect tax Holdings like what are you
gonna do no no no no you don't think
that's ever gonna take your cbdc yeah
you're gonna have your Central Bank
digital currency and it's going to be
Zapped out of your account you don't got
to file taxes anymore don't worry
they're they're gonna do they're gonna
say are you tired of filing taxes it's a
pain in the butt isn't it how about this
with cbdc all automatically done for you
you're gonna think about it I mean the
thing is AI isn't going to do the thing
that we need Community to do right like
you have young children you're married
like if your wife had a medical
emergency in the middle of the night and
you had to take her to the hospital
hopefully your neighbor next door would
come over and sit with your kids right
like there are some things that we just
can't replace with technology and it's
really important to know the people
you're around we talk about it all the
time in terms of being proactive knowing
who your kids are involved with you're
doing business with things like that but
there are times that there's just no
substitute for the people around you Ian
uh you said you said that you sent me
that AI video oh did you we should play
a little bit of that I was just thinking
about it maybe we'll play it uh super
freaky we'll give it like a full segment
yeah that was sent to me by the
architect members on there or something
but this is like what was it like five
minutes or ten minutes how long was it
it was like three three to five three to
five minutes a fully AI generated video
it was AI voice too and no I think
someone did the voice I think it was
only the visuals or AI but I can't tell
whoever did the voice is a genius The
Voice could have easily have been AI
great actor but this is a this is like a
three minute video and we are after
watching this I'm like yeah okay we're a
year away from from bro
we're gonna pull up the AI you're gonna
type in the chat GPT or something and
you're gonna say
Rick generate me a music video of a song
by adelita's way and it will be perfect
the video will play it will be you guys
it will sound like you playing and
singing You'll watch it and say what is
this sounds like an easy way to cancel
anyone look what he said
the worst things ever and I gotta didn't
say that I swear or you can't cancel
anybody anymore yeah because everyone
just says it's AI says about Trump trump
can come out back I was AI look at the
capabilities of what the the there's a
video of the progression of even just a
physical robot and what they can do and
when you watch that video you will be
like that's what robots are doing
nowadays they can do front flips back
flips land comp they're they're so the
the there's a version of a robot out
there right now that's so Advanced that
it's concerning dude there's slight
there's slime robots have you seen them
they're they're amorphous they're like
amoeba and they're robotic they're like
I don't know if they're uh iron graphene
I don't know what they're made of
exactly but they can go around and
through cracks and stuff well they
really they really must be susceptible
to a to ARS because that seems to be the
thing that they want none of us to have
they they they're mounting scrap rifles
onto these these drone dogs have you
seen the videos right
scrap metal because I'm that drone dog's
gonna get blown away right I'm that's
the kind of stuff you got to be ready to
blow away I don't want to go to a Civil
War and hurt no people I don't think
that that the people we're dealing with
even are are brave enough to do that
they seem to kill from afar is by far
the most important thing we can possibly
do right now is build up our drone
defense systems be it robot dogs or
flying swarm drones hit them with a
couple bullets lasers fall out of the
sky well no no no no we should use them
he sang No and we need to learn how to
defend against them too that's coming
like whether it's robots dogs on the
ground or from the sky swarming you from
every angle we need to learn how to
defend again so this is the thing about
war right now it's mostly drones like
we're seeing in Ukraine and stuff and
yeah I think I think you make a good
point in that regard what we are missing
I think is microwave takedown techniques
jamming techniques now the problem is
it's a race it's an arms race they make
more resilient drones you make drone
takedown methods it's just it's going to
be an arms race you know uh an
escalation of the capabilities of these
devices I think people need to consider
this too and I want to save a lot of the
AI stuff we'll talk about this in the
members only but I warned about this 10
years ago I was uh uh me and my guys my
friends we launched the first live
streaming aerial drone and we're we were
broadcasting from Occupy Wall Street
with it we got invited to a bunch of
like University and like government
panel stuff I was selecting like a test
location for where they would begin
setting up and devising regulations on
drones and I told these guys
you need to prepare for when they take
these things and they use them as
Weapons because if one of these things
gets launched from 50 miles away and
then sent full speed towards say New
York City what do you do and they they
don't even know and I'm like this kind
of stuff is as at your doorstep and I'm
and this is a terrifying thing but now
you're seeing it in Ukraine where they
have these videos where they're using
them as weapons of war so we definitely
need our cities to be proactive on this
stuff to prevent it I do think there's
probably really Simple Solutions we
should think about
the problem is what do you do when this
thing falls out of the sky so if you if
you do like infrared lasers on the top
of buildings to Target a drone that you
know an unknown drone or a vessel coming
into your city if you hit that thing to
stop it it falls it's gonna land
somewhere but you know I I don't I don't
have all the answers thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time